hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm we're gonna be making
a lot more videos on chess openings in
lines that people have requested so
today we're gonna be looking at the
mosque a variation very popular line in
the Sicilian offensive a lot of players
just are not sure how to play correctly
so we're gonna look at some of the main
variations some key concepts to think
about if you are playing the Sicilian
offense and someone plays the mosque a
variation if you're not familiar with it
starts out with pawn to e4 pawn c5 this
is the Sicilian defense Knight to f3
pawn to d6 and then Bishop to b5 putting
black in check now there's three ways
that black can respond I'm just going to
ignore the fact that black can play
Queen to d7 you have the knight coming
up here to c6 you know the knight coming
to d7 and you have the Bishop coming
here to a d7 as well a lot of people
have a lot of opinions about which move
is best I think all three moves are
completely fine each of them has their
own unique style to them I think for
many players it's really gonna be up to
you depending on how you like to play a
game of chess what your strengths and
weaknesses are and then the tendencies
of your opponent because there's a lot
of mistakes that white can make in each
variation so we are gonna look at the
three moves today and go over some pros
and cons for each of them
the first raishin we are going to look
at is Knight to d7 a lot of players like
this because they don't want to give
white the option to take their knight
and then have double pawns on the C file
and they don't want to give up their
bishop even if is in exchange for
White's own Bishop so they play Knight
to d7 white really is going to take the
knight but if they do just go ahead and
take back with your Bishop don't take
with your Queen it's a little awkward
tough to get the LightSquared Bishop
involved into the action now because the
Queen is blocking it and then you're
gonna have to push this pawn just to get
involved go ahead and take with your
Bishop now the bishop cadiz will get
involved Queen to c7 or b6 depending on
what your opponent does is going to be a
great option for
Queen so white does have some other
options you will see one of the most
common is going to be pawn to d4 pushing
in the center of the board and Black has
three main options from here and I'll go
over a few of them and why I like them
or don't like them one that you'll see
black make a lot not the recommended
move for me is to go ahead and take with
the pawn here on d4 reason I don't like
it as much that's saying it's a terrible
move but white can take with the Queen
just has a very active position normally
you would like to see something like
pawn to e5 but now there's a backward
pawn here on d6 very easy for white to
attack this black really wants his not
here on b8
so he can play up here to c6 pushing the
Queen back though just great option and
the Queen is just putting so much
pressure on black you could see all this
material for White's getting very
aggressive where blacks just kind of
sitting here with his knight pinned down
to his King trying to figure out how
he's going to develop his material so
not necessarily my favorite another
option black has is to force the action
on this bishop so pawn to a6 and now if
white wants to go ahead and take hey
that's completely fine black in
recapture doesn't have to worry about as
much pressure right now and then can
continue in the game maybe the the pawn
takes now if the pawn takes play Queen
up here to a5 don't take with the pawn
right away this is check now if we see
the knight come down here to c3 blocking
this the Queen can come over and take
solidifying the pawn chain still in the
center the board not giving up enter any
of this Center pawn so this is going to
be fine for black maybe Bishop to e3
Queen up here to c4 Queen d2 this is
going to be a fine variation for black
if we come back to this position white
might not take this night here on d7
could easily come back to c4 and in this
case I would just push forward with the
pawns pawn to b5 forcing the bishop to
move if he comes to d5 just play rook to
b8 this is fine maybe castle on the
kingside Knight
to f6 attacking this bishop right here
sometimes you'll have someone who's not
very familiar with the position and
after pawn to a6 they'll just come back
to a4 because they've maybe applied the
played the right Lopes and they're just
used to coming back here to a4 but this
would be a huge mistake you can probably
see it already
pawn to b5 forcing the bishop to move
but after here pawn to c4 that Bishop is
going to fall so blacks gonna be up in
material after that exchange now if we
come back maybe instead upon to a6 black
wants to try something else and it could
just play Knight to f6 I think this is a
fine variation as well you could see
white just take the pawn right here on
c5 this is another spot where I wouldn't
take with the pawn I would play queen up
here to a 5 and this is even better than
the position we just looked at because
the knight on f6 is attacking this pawn
on e4 why is that important this is
check it's also attacking the bishop
here on b5 so usually white should be
playing Knight to c3 if he doesn't this
bishop is going to fall but now black
can play Knight takes on e4 gobbling up
a center pawn and the knight can't move
because it is pinned down to this Queen
so maybe Queen to d3 attacking the
knight but then the knight can come back
and take that pawn on c5 so this is a
really good variation for black if
you're looking to what to do when your
opponent plays that pawn to d4 now
they're not always going to go to d4
another option would be to come to c3
knowing that they're light square Bishop
is still going to be pinning down this
Knight it's not under any pressure right
now to move so they may just continue to
develop as they normally would
now after Knight to c3 black has a
couple option one would just be to to
force the action say I don't like being
pinned down right here I'm gonna play
pawn to a6 we already know if they take
the night we're gonna recapture with our
Bishop but if they if they come back we
already know it's going to be a mistake
if they come back to a4 more than likely
they're going to retreat and that's
going to be completely fine another
option would be in
of playing pawn to a6 just go ahead and
play Knight to f6 now if they decide to
you know castle on the kingside I'd play
pawn to g6 get ready to fianchetto to
the king side of the board now if they
decide from here to go ahead and take
the knight we're still going to take
with our bishop even though our knight
could take we're still gonna be taking
with our bishop now if we come back they
may not play Knight to c3 they could try
something else
castle on the King side very logical
move you still have the same options you
could play that pawn to a6 and force the
action or you could play Knight to f6
I'm generally going to be playing the
Knight to f6 unless I'm playing someone
that I actually think is going to make a
mistake and play Bishop back here to a4
and I can you know get some material I'm
more interested in getting King safety
pawn to g6 being kind of my bishop here
to g7 castle on the King side and the
Queen side the board tends to work
itself out an expiration we are going to
look at is when black plays Bishop to d7
a lot of players like this because it
forces the action where when you play
your knight you're not putting any
pressure on white they can just sit here
on b5 as long as they want to and you
have to worry about that piece just
being pinned down where here it says
yeah we can exchange our material if you
want to but I'm gonna force you to make
a decision if you want to retreat that's
completely fine play Bishop back here to
e2 you somewhat wasted a move now I just
can continue to develop my pieces Knight
to f6 even if they don't want to take
this material right here let me say
Queen to e2 great you can continue to
develop your pieces you can take the
bishop anytime you want to you do have
the choice in Allen stead of just
waiting for your opponent to take the
piece or not so it doesn't really matter
where they go even Knight to c3 I'm
playing Knight to f6 as well most of the
time since you are forcing them and they
don't want to retreat they're just going
to go ahead and take this Bishop here on
d7 when they do that go ahead and take
with your queen don't take with your
knight very valuable for you to be able
to play Knight to c6 in this specific
variation many times they are going to
be getting a piece here to d4 after some
exchanges and knowing that you can play
Knight to c6 forcing that material to
leave retreats lose a move in tempo is
extremely important
now after black recaptures on d7 White
has a lot of options as you can imagine
one of the most common ones would be to
push forward with d4 trying to
capitalize on the center of the board
when they do this you're going to
capture with your own pawn here and then
they have a few options from here one of
the options would be to castle on the
King side knowing that they have the
knight and the Queen both attacking they
may decide not to go ahead and get that
material right away they can if they
want too many times though they will
also just take with their queen knowing
that they they have this option here if
the Queen comes to d4 as we've talked
about Knight to c6 forcing the Queen to
come back here I'll say Queen to d3
Knight to f6 simple development move
maybe Knight to c3 and then I'm playing
pawn to g6 that would come back maybe
it's not Knight to c3 maybe it's castle
on the King side I'm still playing pawn
to g6 the one slight variation which
would be different is instead of those
moves if they played Bishop down here to
g5 I'm no longer playing pawn to g6 that
you hopefully you can see this would be
a bad option Bishop takes here pawn
captures and you can see not only a
double pawn not necessarily the worst
thing to have double pawns if you have
support next to it but now there's an
isolated pawn here on d6 not the
position that black is going for so most
of the time we're going to be playing
pawn to g6 but do look out for white
coming down and playing Bishop down to
g5 now instead of d4 they may try
something like Knight to c3 and I
consider this more of a no-pressure move
we're d4 it's putting pressure on this
end of the board it's attacking our
material Knight to c3 is a simple
development move and it's allowing us to
do what we want and when I see this type
of move I'm looking to play something
like
on to g6 feeing keto on the kingside the
board that's gonna be a constant theme
throughout getting our Bishop here to g7
as quickly as possible and then Knight
to f6 at some point and those moves may
vary a little bit sometimes you're gonna
be playing Knight to f6 first depending
on where your opponent goes because you
may want to use that as an attack maybe
you're gonna be taking here on e4
depending on where they're going but
many times I'm looking for the pawn to
g6 from here if they decide pawn to d4
you can take their Queen can capture in
the knight to f6 you know now maybe the
knight comes down to d5 attacking our
knight I'm playing Bishop to g7 maybe
the bishop comes down now I'm castling
on the King side maybe instead of the
Knights coming down here to d5 maybe
they first come down to g5 I'm still at
this point thinking about coming up to
Bishop here to g7 but first I'm gonna
have the in-between move of Knight to c6
forcing the Queen to move and at that
point I can bring my bishop here to g7
so always be thinking about if the Queen
is here on d4 how you can get your
knight up here to c6 force the Queen
back another option you may see is pawn
to c4 and from here I'm usually just
playing pawn to g6 getting ready to
fianchetto to the King side of the board
now from here if they push in the center
of the board because that's what they're
trying to do saying yeah you're not
trying to defend too much in the center
I'm gonna push forward I'm gonna play
Knight to f6 this pawn on d6 is doing a
good job of stopping white pushing
forward in the board but I'm not ready
to push forward with this pawn on e5 you
have a backwards pawn here on d6
it is very difficult to defend this you
want to get your Bishop here on a g7 so
you don't want this tying down to this
this pawn right here on d6 and you want
a very active Queen if you can so I
don't like to commit right away with
this eeep on I like to wait for that
fianchetto on the King side of the board
maybe castle bring my recovery here to e
eight to protect upon and then push if I
want to now from here if they decide to
go ahead and take material so let's say
pawn takes on c5 I wouldn't take with
this home pawn I'm always trying to try
to hold on to the center pawns I would
first take the pawn up here on e4 and
then usually the Queen's going to get
involved attacking this because if the
pawn were to take right here the knight
could come back that's also attacking
the pawn here on c5 so this knight on e4
really allows us to dictate how we take
back without compromising our pawn
structure but if the Queen comes down we
can just bring our knight back here to
f6 and things are completely fine and
white no longer has any central pawns
now if instead of the pawn to c4 if they
just do something like king castle on
the King side similar to when night came
to c3 I think of this as a no-pressure
move and I'm playing pawn to g6 so
always be thinking about and are they
putting pressure on me and if not go
ahead and start to fianchetto on the
King side of the board the laceration we
are going to look at is when the night
comes to c6 this is my preferred
variation for black I know a lot of
people have their own opinions on how
they like to play but for me Knight to
c6 is my go-to move if I'm playing this
is silly in defense and someone responds
with the Moscow variation because
honestly I don't care if they take my
knight on c6 yes I am going to have
double pawns on the C file but this
control is a very important square here
on d5 and it's gonna be easy long-term
to get rid of this double pawn but it
gets rid of their bishop pair right away
I now it's very easy for me to get my
light square bishop involved into the
action because this pawn here on b7 is
not there so very quick rapid
development for black I can get my Queen
here to c7 very quickly to control the
dark squares in the center and all of a
sudden white doesn't have a ton of
material involved into the game they've
moved their
a couple moves and then it's no longer
on the board so I'm okay
with this variation now from here white
has lots of moves they could do same
thing could play pawn to d4 in the
center I'm gonna go ahead and take with
my pawn I'm always looking for
opportunities to get rid of the the
double pawns here on the C file and
usually if I can take a pawn that was on
the C file and take a center pun from
white that is what I'm going to be doing
so I'll leave I'll be looking at that
option for sure and then later if I want
to get Knight to f6 I think that's going
to be completely fine as well now if
they decide to go ahead and take Knight
takes on d4 then you have some options
here but you can push forward with pawn
to e5 and I think that's completely fine
if they decide to come down here and
play Queen to c6 because we're almost
baiting them to do this then you can
play Queen to b6 in the knight is going
to full and black is gonna be up
material and many times I they look at
this and they feel like it looks like a
free pawn here that they can take
actually it's not you are going to gain
material in that position now instead of
pawn to d4 maybe they decide to castle
on the King side I'm playing Queen to c7
in this spots you want to keep the door
open for the light squared bishop to get
involved into the action this pawn on c6
just as a spoiler alert if they're not
going to allow you to play something
like pawn to d4 and exchange material
and get rid of the double pawns this
pawn on c6 does need some attention your
opponent can attack this later on to the
game so making sure that you can defend
this with the Queen as well as these
dark squares in the center of the board
many times there is going to be a lot of
pressure building up right here so
having another layer of protection from
this Queen is going to be crucial now
another thing you could see instead of
castle on the King side is pawn to d3
solidifying the pawn chain I'm playing
the same thing Queen to c7 now maybe
Knight to c3 I'm playing Knight to f6
castle on the King side I'm playing
to g6 game ready to fianchetto to the
king side of the board now they may
decide I'm not even gonna take that
nights here on c6 although that is the
more common move but they may recognize
that they don't want to give up their
bishop here they could play something
you know pawn to d4 if they want to
that's fine they could take we could
take right here and then Bishop to d7
this is great because now if they ever
want to take the Knights it's not
pinning down our King anymore then we
can just recapture with our Bishop we
have a very active square for our Bishop
at that point completely fine for black
if they play more of a no-pressure move
pawn to d3 as you probably guess I'm
playing pawn to g6 and then at some
point I'm gonna play Bishop here to d7
but I do want to go ahead and fee and
get on my bishop here to d7 because I'm
not too concerned about them taking my
knight I can easily recapture here at
pawn to c6 with my pawn so that's an
overview of the Moscow variation try out
the different options Knight to c6
Knight to d7 or even Bishop to d7 see
what you like but hopefully this was a
good intro overview give you some things
to think about if you like to play the
Sicilian offense and your opponent's
ever played Bishop to b5 and you just
did not know where to move so thank you
guys for watching if you have any other
suggestions on openings or variations
that you would like to see feel free to
email me at the chess website at
gmail.com thanks again I'll see you guys
in the next video